foreign
is taken into custody just north of the
Border after leading officials on a
chase throughout southeast Wisconsin
after he's taken into custody he lashes
out at sheriff's deputies and allegedly
tries to escape again
it all started on July 15th when police
in Park Ridge Illinois were transporting
Lake County Jail inmate Wesley Anderson
officials say Anderson started acting
out and slipped his handcuffs from
behind his back to in front of his body
when officers pulled over to contain
Anderson he broke free and ran across
traffic on Interstate 294. Anderson then
forced a driver out of their van and
drove off in the stolen vehicle
officials say he later switched to a
stolen Camaro that he drove about an
hour north from where he escaped it was
the OnStar system in that Camaro that
led Wisconsin officials to his location
[Music]
foreign
officials with both the Pleasant Prairie
Police Department and Kenosha County
Sheriff's Department released dash
camera video of the chase
[Music]
video shows the chase go from high speed
to extremely slow as First Responders
follow Anderson onto the Interstate
[Music]
foreign
ly Anderson comes to a stop
[Music]
video shows First Responders from both
departments spring into action
he's got a handcuffs on
hands up
it's not now
body camera video shows officials
approach Anderson in the vehicle as they
work to take him into custody
lethal
we'll move nice and slow boys yep nice
and slow
Anderson can be heard repeating please
don't kill me as he seemingly begins
crying
anymore
if you reach for anything even
do you understand
all right are you fight anybody you're
good at me please
all right
this closer let me see your other hand
let's see your hands let's go right here
okay please do not just taste me excuse
me please somebody got a scissors please
don't hit me please don't hit me I won't
hurt you please
thank you
why'd you do that to me baby
[Music]
once he's in custody officials take
Anderson to an area Hospital video shows
him arguing with Kenosha County
sheriff's deputies about a bedpan
IC
assist me
you just bring in the bed hand for you
all right
it's then that he lashes out and
attempts to escape again
[Music]
stop stop
give me units the hospital
393 shave requesting additional units
not bad
I just need to use the washroom get on
the bed now lay on the bed Anderson was
later taken to the Kenosha County jail
he now faces multiple charges including
first degree recklessly endangering
safety and operating a vehicle without
consent reporting for long crime Network
I'm Sierra Gillespie